did you shake hands with Brandon no I
did anything this and I would wash my
hands too you're fine okay so Brandon
again so give me a sec what's up Brandon
Brian how are you he's audio still
communicating all right you should be
able to speak now what's up hi what's up
crew on a buddy not much buddy boy I'm
just hanging out pretty much fine I'm
pretty much 100% [ __ ] are we recording
we're rolling yep we're good we should
know that Brendan and I did everything
wrong in Texas we basically we know
social distancing got up in front of 350
people as they were laughing at us and
scouting at us in a we got off stage
didn't change mics shared it with Malik
and Stevie Stevie sick as a [ __ ] dog
he's he's the corona poster boy lost his
sense of taste smell and then we would
walk through a crowd of people going
yeah irresponsible [ __ ] and now it
looks like Brendan's got coronavirus and
I'm still waiting for my tests right
well well here's the thing to all that
okay well I'm glad you on that rant
Kallen and here's the thing though like
I said you know Corona is something you
know I never said it was not real
anything like that I went about living
my life I got it and you know what I'm
fine well I'm not gonna do this weird
thing with you what most people just
like my doctor told me he goes what your
what you're experiencing 97% of all
people get Corona experienced the same
thing so this podcast isn't gonna be a
poor Cooper oh no poor Brian poor
Brendan this is a thing where I was
living my life
I got Corona I'm fine it might say
Emily's fine
we I bunkered down i quarantined and
that's what it is man is it weird that I
worked out today is it weird that on day
three I've worked out because I have
energy do I look like I'm sick it's
interesting I'm waiting for my results
we'll see what happens but if I feel do
you have it Stevie has it you know my
flu symptoms are not look it's true I
talked to my doctor who said for the
most part symptoms were all over the
place and you know and I said I gotta be
honest with you I can I'm moving about
my dad and he said that's very calm yeah
I mean you should you shouldn't be
moving about your day you should still
stay quarantined if yes I'm saying
quarantine I'm gonna give it to anybody
yeah I don't want I'm not going anywhere
yeah cuz I think I'm trying to be
responsible definitely now now I
understand never call anywhere and if I
had to go anywhere I would wear a mask
and I'd be outside you know cuz I just
don't I don't wanna be responsible for
giving it to anybody no that's the whole
thing that's what I'm gonna do the
podcast like this you know because if
dude if you have underlying health
conditions if you're especially if
you're obese or if you're older yeah you
I mean you know we got it I mean there's
we're morons and we went about you know
showing the torn stuff we did everything
wrong agree with that I don't agree with
that B you did we did everything wrong
and what fat like if you didn't want to
catch it
like we went to when we were on our way
Saturday to do our final shows in San
Antonio
we got an Amber Alert that said listen
cases are spiked and you can't come in
so 90 90 people canceled on us the first
show but we have to do we have to do a
show I mean that's the other thing about
being a comic we saw a lot of tickets I
got to do the show we weren't we were
responsible wash their hands and stuff
like that but you're you're gonna catch
something I think if you're if you're
performing on stage all those people and
that was a risk that I took
responsibility for and I was willing to
take responsibility for so yeah I think
if you were any older if you let if you
if you were your age count you had
underlying health issues like obesity or
diabetes or you had pneumonia before son
like that
yeah Christ should be on tour my man if
I wasn't if I wasn't born
healthy and shredded right and here's
the thing I hate to do this to you I
think you're jumping on the crow to
train I don't really think you have it
I gotta be honest you you tested
negative you tested negative and if
you're trying to jump on the train
that's a car that's a [ __ ] car you
said that you guys are on a train that's
[ __ ] dude I saw you tell you huh I
saw you test they said you didn't have
it now you took another one because I
woke up all kinds of aching yeah I don't
know oh dude look you trying to jump on
this train you don't know dude
you worried because just [ __ ] now hey
cat and chill are you guys worried about
any of it yeah okay I feel like I have a
slight fever but I don't think I have it
I think that's just from wearing long
sleeves to being around my family
because I have to hide my tattoos that's
it yep tattoo still uh they do they just
my mom doesn't like senior chin open the
podcast with I've been having pains my
shoulders in my neck earlier we did a
test I was like I've been having these
pains forever so I can't tell if it's
from corona or not I don't know for six
years huh hey chin yeah this girlfriend
of yours
don't stare is it possible the cheese
she's being a burner she's being an
amazing human being she's taking care of
her sister's kids in Orange County and
if she ends up being a he we don't give
a B I've seen her I've seen it you guys
know her yeah I saw him camping yeah
she's a cutie you know what the you know
what the worst thing about this whole
corona is so Sunday when I was flying I
started to feel just like almost I
always get sick on planes but I didn't
feel great I'm like man what's
going on and then I was like it's right
just like a cold thing and then Monday
again didn't feel great that's when you
guys saw me get the I being it and I
also got tested on Monday and then it's
like the symptoms we're always like you
know when your right not to get like a
bad flu and yes like experience the
symptoms like here we go it's like the
very start of a cold or flu but it just
stayed ease there and it does yeah it
doesn't get any worse yeah and then I
quarantine for three days now and then I
woke up this morning one hundred one
hundred percent price I don't know what
it is but I feel better than I've felt
in a long time but the worst thing about
it is your taste and smell leaves yes I
can't like
I'll make the strongest coffee in the
world I can't taste anything so weird
like nothing I can't taste anything as
you're talking you know what I realized
much to my depression my eyes look
exactly the same
oh they look dude you look identical
there's no change zero change like I
still see miss well thanks a lot dr.
no-help hey Kay can I be honest about
your doctor yeah you made you look a
little older Ivy's [ __ ] he goes look
at you and look at me that's all you
need to say like how did we look about
the same age yeah I mean I don't know
what your thing is against Ivy's I've
got an IV every day including today to
knock this thing out well obviously it's
working because you're a hundred percent
you woke up going I have zero symptoms
and day to day to zero IV what's in the
IV are you doing the other the other
magic [ __ ] that stops no I've done an ad
drips before those suck man those hurt
you know I think I'd rather look older
than deal with that all the time really
I'll tell you what I can't wait to do my
dad doesn't have corona I can't wait to
call him and tell him and then rub it in
his face
that's what I can't wait to do my dad
he's
he's a CNN he's a CNN junkie oh dude you
have no idea you have no idea you have
no it's amazing well we're back on
lockdown
I think no we're not no what do you mean
la feels like it's still on lockdown not
lockdown but they're quote so wineries
restaurants also if you can't dine in we
can dine out do that you can dine out
the the beaches are closed just for July
4th but people are gonna listen to that
New York City is closing off the entire
streets and restaurants just put all
their stuff dirty tables outside it's
pretty cool these streets right yeah
everyone's outside yeah it's cool yeah
it's nice I'm curious I'm curious to see
how long this Corona fare things didn't
keep going because a statistic just came
out today with Florida which is just
booming with all these cases and I sent
this to you can you look at the deaths
it's point four of deaths of all the
cases 4% so it's like all the death
rates are going like this but the
coronaviruses friend like this but
deaths are down so it's like I don't
know how much longer they be able to
hang on to this well I hope that I come
up back positive because I want to get
it so I don't have to worry about it
if there's a time again it's probably
not you know on our friend our friend
Jeff Foley told us who's the owner of
tempest Jim's out - Jeff Foley goes I
know dude I can't take tiger at your gym
on Friday man I I got hit with that code
good he goes can I be honest can you
still come and rub it in my face I can
get it over with
yeah exactly right now everybody is
essentially apparently gonna get it I
mean you know but hopefully we had
better therapeutics so I talked to my
buddy as a doctor who had it and he
works at UCLA and I said what drugs
would I take him I do and he goes right
now nothing there's other things you can
take but there's this HIV drug you to
take it's really bad you don't need to
do that there'll be if you if you don't
have I talked to my doctor - he's like
are you experiencing severe staph or you
know yes that's the only worst-case
there's some side effects that stuff too
you know
you know you guys know if you listen the
podcast I've been going hard on Kron and
stuff like that but I got I was a ghost
[ __ ] oh man this this could get dicey I
you know I even I got scared from all
that fear porn okay the question but
even my doctor was like dude knowing how
healthy you are and stuff like that
you're gonna experience mild symptoms I
bet you get over it really quick I was
like I hope so
I had images of you and I both on
ventilators me too and we like we can't
do the podcast just [ __ ] die in what
the [ __ ] those two [ __ ] who have
been going hard in the paint against
Corona just [ __ ] die
no I'm glad I got it because now I can
talk from a personal experience I'll see
Mike Mike's wrench is different than
some people but for the majority of
people under 40 this is what it's like
dude can I show you guys a question can
I ask you a question seriously you look
67 years old I have I have Corona but
I'm looking at my skin tone and the
tightness of it and I don't think I look
a day over 40 it's [ __ ] weird you
know there's a few lies there the county
Greece take your babies Brian does a few
lines they're eight you don't have
Corona you got the test that said you
didn't have it you don't know that let
me check hold on a little bit so bad so
he can act like he is something to talk
about you answer yes you you are you are
well the doctor said full-blown huh yeah
is this the same doctor who did your
lids and called you bro yeah yeah he
said well said bro you have full-blown
Corona congratulations you are I believe
if anybody can fight this you can't pass
the count he's doing aegyo better same
worse he goes discouraging man I thought
I was feeling better last night woke up
three times soaked in sweat had to
shower and change the sheets feel the
same today
Stevie's all [ __ ] up well remember -
Steve has underlying health conditions
Stevie he's had cancer and had his legs
see we spent days 12 to 13 in a
wheelchair and they had full-blown
[ __ ] lymphoma and almost died that's
why Stevie sleeps for
he's delicate like steve yes-man what's
wrong Steve you knew hey stevie has no
health insurance
he doesn't have health insurance so I
better be okay though
hey I think you'll be okay I think it's
just manifests itself differently in
people does your does your girl have it
be I think she's sick - yeah but she's
feeling better
she's feeling better already did she get
uh did she get tested for it or though
she got tested so we're waiting on the
test
we're probably you wish you like you're
like Tom Hanks no but here's the thing
is you keep yeah I don't know you need
to talk to your doctor cuz my doctor
goes you guys to when I've got in San
Antonio you got away before then really
yeah he goes let's say you got to San
Antonio on Thursday the symptoms aren't
gonna show up that fast I was between
three days and 10 weeks yeah well my my
doctors say it's between 4 to 14 days
well you know what shows me as they have
no [ __ ] clue what they're talking
about but the other thing is is my
brother-in-law had it two weeks ago so
and I was with him riding bikes and we
were making out yes closed room yes
making out with somebody gives it to you
guilty why you guys where's Brian
you must be his wife I or I don't know
there he goes you're back that was weird
I have four bars okay here's the
question when can we go back into studio
two weeks no not true because if I'm
gonna get tested I talk to show time get
tested again on Monday because I'm yep
as soon as you have a negative test you
can come back that's right that's what I
have to do
I'm positive for sure I'm nice can't
wait yours gonna be another negative you
have no excuse not to do the podcast
yeah I have a test set up for Monday so
I assume but if I'm fine now by Monday I
should be alright hopefully I'm if I
have Co but then this is a very mild
case of code I have to say but that's
how it is be like my brother in law he
was like I had a ego is the worst part
for me as I had a scratchy throat for
three days and he tested positive for it
a lot of young people have very mild
symptoms are they very symptomatic not
even young dude 45 90% have this same
symptoms quit spreading lies Brian you
have it and it's not [ __ ] dude I have it
it's not now what you should well you
shouldn't do Brian is go buy it and go
to your parents though cuz your dad yeah
I can't take that risk
no meaning like my my girls parents
they're usually always over watching the
tiger in Boston they're not coming over
by for two weeks
yeah that's the bummer
um that is the bar but I can't risk
getting them sick were you going for
anything particular you're just going to
see you just want to take my kids and
hang with you know just kind of get away
I love you and your dad getting a good
argument I love hanging with numb but
yeah we argue like cats and dogs and
we're you haven't told him you have you
testified I was waiting for a while I
was waiting cuz if I was on a ventilator
if you've been you know I [ __ ] told
you so I've been waiting I've been I've
been in the corona tall grass I sure did
Brian and then what else I did 15 miles
today and then what else I'm doing is
I'm building a bike right now in the
garage a new bike I'm building a new
bike from white to I'm tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]